hello out there it is the Friday before
Halloween yeah and as such for our movie
review I'm finally getting around to one
that I've been dying to do for a really
really really long time because I'm so
so into Italian horror and I really
haven't done a lot of them on the show
like I did I did what about Suspiria
when tom was away so I did that one kind
of on my own I think that's the only
Italian movie I've done so far even
though I'm like a really big huge fan of
them so I've been waiting forever to do
some Lucio Fulci and today we are gonna
do that [ __ ] yeah we're doing the Beyond
yeah one of his best movies actually I
think it's his best movie probably
zombie is his best-known at least in the
United States and the UK but I actually
think the beyond is this most
accomplished film I came out in 1981 the
thing about full G is that in the US and
the UK to a you know to the same extent
he's kind of known as you know the
Godfather of gore you know the horror
guy and survival guy even though yeah
and the eyeball guy if there's eyeballs
he's gonna poke them out it pretty much
yes and there's something in Dhoom or
poke or mash the eye out or step on the
eyes just yeah mess with that and there
are many many examples yeah beyond you
know so I think that this has most his
most most examples of ocular mayhem I
think you're an to be on my issue but
the interesting thing about him is that
he actually directed movies I think
about 50 movies and only a kind of a
small percentage of them were horror
movies he also did westerns he did
musicals he did comedies he did some
Jolla movies actually he did a really
good one which i think is sort of
underrated which is called the psychic
or murder to the tone of seven black
notes which I might actually do at some
point because I think that it's one that
doesn't get a lot of attention and I
really like it like I really like the
script and the way it's shot is really
cool but we are talking today about as I
said the beyond now the beyond is
actually the second film in his loose
conglomeration known as the he'll
trilogy or the gates of Hell trilogy the
first movie was from 1980 and it's
called City the Living Dead or the gates
of Hell goes under both of those titles
the third one was came out in 1983 it
was called the house by the cemetery now
these are all standalone movies but they
have the same theme of like a hell
portal or a place like a cursed place
that has like a doorway to hell hell
underneath it another similar thing is
that catcher Anna McCall the British
actress who stars in the beyond is
actually in all three of them although
she's playing three different characters
so there's kind of that theme attic
element also when you watch these movies
you can kind of see where John Carpenter
got a lot of his inspirations for some
of his crazier movies too because he was
taking movies and put them together in
trilogies even though they were
stand-alones yeah like he's got what the
thing he had like an apocalypse yeah
yeah it was the thing escape from New
York came from New York and what was
that other one the Prince of Darkness
yeah which he said those were all kind
of interrelated it's like a thematic
series not really like a you know
numerical sequencer yeah and they do
kind of feel like Italian flicks yeah
you could see where he was gay well he's
hugely influenced by particularly Dario
Argento and Dario jente do the same
thing with his quote-unquote three
mothers trilogy which you know they're
three movies that standalone you know
it's Suspiria and Ferno mother of Tears
but they have like the same theme of
like a witch in a different place yeah
you know what I mean the the thing
wasn't didn't have too much of an
Italian flair to it I didn't think but
that Prince of Darkness one did that was
like a nonsensical Italian horror
yeah because you asked me these movies
are cool to watch they look good they
don't make a whole lot of sense to me
all the time well they don't make sense
to a lot of people because you do
something you have to think about
Italian horror movie
Lucia full cheese movies Dario Argento's
movies Italian horror movies in general
narrative focus narrative coherence is
not their main goal particularly the
horror movie genre what they're trying
to do is just they're trying to
establish a mood or they're trying to
establish atmosphere they tend to like
the set pieces they like really gruesome
like operatic sort of set pieces
and they'll just kind of write a sort of
coherent story that will you know link
those scenes together yeah just because
they kind of like they're they're all
about the the optics you know what I
mean right how it look you can have a
character in the story climbing up a
ladder fall down bust his ass and for
some unexplained reason get eaten up by
try Angelus
yeah you know and then long prolonged
scenes of being eaten by tranchida's
you're not really clear why this has
happened
well but you do go damn what the hell
they were tech guesses but they yes what
he wanted he wanted you to not you know
to just be stupefied I guess well and
the thing to particularly about
fortunate you know about the Beyond and
about his hell trilogy was that one they
had a they started working on the beyond
from essentially a three-page treatment
they didn't have an entire script they
had an idea of where they were going
with it they had an idea of like some
death scenes they wanted to do and kind
of a rough idea of the story but they
did a lot of it on the fly
so they're actually kind of like he's
almost kind of like and I don't know if
this was I suspected it was on purpose
because Lucio Fulci started out as as an
art critic before he was a filmmaker I
suspect that he was a big fan of like
surrealism and so he wasn't too
concerned about things making sense he's
just like I want to do to fall off a
ladder and get eaten by tarantulas and
make it work like figure out how to put
that in the movie it doesn't make any
sense but the thing about you know the
the hell trilogy particularly the beyond
is that because the whole premise of the
movie is that a portal to Hell has been
open to our portal to like some kind of
like horrible dimension has been opened
you can get away with a lot of [ __ ] in
that movie because you can just say well
you know demons are coming out or the
dead are rising and stuff and like you
know it's just gonna make it so that
it's bringing your worst fears to life
or something like that so something that
I have sees people that don't it italian
horror it's like you either like it and
get it or you don't because it very much
is predicated upon you just being able
to roll with it and just whatever
happens that was cool
don't try to make sense of it
but I think I'm kind of in the middle I
tolerate it
yeah I do like it but it does kind of
frustrate me because you're trying to
follow a story and then that story kind
of vanishes and then another story kind
of comes in then you forget and there
was cut at the end there was kind of an
overarching story but you kind of forgot
what that was but then again I'm not I
don't have I'm not really known for
having like immeasurable patience
talking about I get kind of an
understatement what I do is you just you
just have a few drinks you watch the
[ __ ] just trip out on it yeah that's you
know and don't don't try to read too
much into it just enjoy it yeah I said
just roll with it yeah I would I would
actually like to have a more coherent
story yeah yeah I like character-driven
stories think think right hands know
that if it doesn't have any really
awesome characters that I like then I
don't care about the movie now saying
it's got a bad movie it's just not for
me yeah you just can't you you can't
like find a place to get yeah I'm not
into it yeah yeah I'm just kind of like
I said I'm a very laid-back like movie
goer I will probably I'm very open to a
lot of different film styles so it's
like whatever the person shows like you
know show me what you got I want to see
what your vision is I'm gonna see what
you're trying to do and then I either
like it or I don't but I'm very willing
to give people like the benefit of the
doubt and just kind of let it roll
whatever it is they're doing if it's
weird or whatever I don't really care so
I so I immediately like got into Italian
horror and you know back in the day
because I was just kind of like oh I see
what they're doing here and it's like
cool-looking and it sort of makes sense
enough that you don't really mind so the
thing about the beyond there actually is
kind of a story behind it it actually
opened in Italy in 1981 now it didn't
get a theatrical release in the US until
1983 and interestingly about that was
that the production company that picked
it up actually cut about eight or nine
minutes out of the movie mostly the gore
so they could get an R rating put a
totally different score on it which I
thought that was kind of strange cuz I
kind of liked the prog rocky score that
it has even though you think it doesn't
work but just like Dario gent yeah a
little bit actually that's kinda that's
first started to kick in I was like what
the hell is this yeah because it's a
little Goblin yeah
starts off as like an 1800s night-night
1927 1927 1927 alright so it's but it's
in New Orleans which that looks 1800s
alright just the architecture and
everything and then out of blue just
comes like 60s sound and 70 sound and
like prog rock it be a music and what
the [ __ ] is this a lot of Italian movies
did that at the time it had flames and
stuff but I went yeah so interestingly
like I said so seven or eight minutes
were or eight or nine minutes of the
movie was cut out and then it was
released under the title seven doors of
death now this kind of made the rounds
of the u.s. like in grindhouse theaters
and stuff like that it wasn't super well
reviewed people said well doesn't make
any sense what I'm like well obviously
because they took a whole bunch of [ __ ]
out of it and they took out all the gore
which was like the best part so actually
people in the United States did not see
an uncut version of the beyond until
1998 and you might find this really
interesting but Quentin Tarantino's
grindhouse releasing and sage Stallone
of all people Sylvester Stallone son
who's actually really into Italian
movies and stuff like that
he actually oversaw the restoration of
the original cut of the beyond so him in
Quentin Tarantino got the movie
re-released a theatrical release in 1998
it kind of made the rounds of the United
States and then it came out later on on
DVD in its final uncut form finally and
people could see it now if you had seen
like the shitty seven doors of death
version which was the version that
circulated back in the 80s on VHS then
you would be forgiven for thinking this
was a shitty chiefly well it was cheaply
made but you know just like a shitty
looking movie because it was pan and
scan it's like you know just grotty
looking and it wasn't really well done
or anything like that but if you see it
now because I actually I saw it on
shutter and I also have the Anchor Bay
DVD that came out several years ago it's
actually a beautifully shot movie and
the first the first prologue of it which
is all like you know sepia tone and
stuff set in 1927 Louisiana is actually
kind of showcasing full cheese and the
cinematographer
grasp of like black and white and like
light and shadow and it's like really
really cool-looking yes so this is a
really really nice-looking movie when
you see it in the form that it was
supposed to be seen in yeah it looked
high-quality to me it really did and
like I said it wasn't made for very much
money um you know like like a lot of
Italian movies at the time weren't they
were very cheaply made
but obviously full Chi was not a hack he
didn't know what he was doing looks as
you know concerning shot composition and
things of that nature the weird thing
about it as an American I look at that
look at that version of it you know
because it looked really nice ya think
if they went through all that trouble to
shoot it that beautifully they could
have had a better script I think with a
more coherent story more driving I would
think yeah but like I said it was it's
not their main gist they're not their
thing that was just it's a cultural
thing ultra thing particularly is horror
movie sound like they have the Italians
have an ice cream called spumoni where
you just take every damn flavor and put
it in the same in that ice cream yeah
you know that's not for everybody it's
just well yeah but like I said it's
called makes the world interest yeah and
that's that's the way fault she was
gonna do a movie it's Pomona yeah
basically spumoni film well I guess the
Danny West is called spumoni horror I
had I actually have a book about Italian
horror that's called spaghetti
nightmares okay but um but yeah so there
is like I said there is kind of a story
to this Katriona mccall like I said
she's a British actress and she was in
all three of full cheese hell trilogy
movies she plays a woman named Liza from
New York City and she gets called to New
Orleans after some uncle that she barely
knew dies and leaves her this hotel
called the seven doors Hotel in
Louisiana this was actually filmed at
Otis house which is a quite famous
historic property in Louisiana which
still stands today if you want to go
visit it you could say hey this is where
they shot the beyond Wow they survived
the storm yeah like as far as I know and
so it most of most of the exteriors most
of the interiors were actually shot in
New Orleans pretty much the only stuff
they had to shoot some of the roll
special effects intense stuff they had
to shoot that in a studio in Rome it's
kind of funny it was shooting all this
stuff they were going through Decatur
Street and everything and of course
that's where I used to hang out
was living in all the girls opposed to
Mississippi recently you know well in
the 90s is when I was living there and
it's just funny cuz they're showing me
all these places that I'm associating
with the old God scene yeah yes this
does very southern gothic kind of feel
it's awesome illustrate the heat though
it's yeah very hot and it's very humid
and moss and mold grows on everything
there and it has a certain smell to it
it has a smell of drying up Blake bed at
certain times of the years it's just
weird I know that smell Florida smells
like that yeah it's - no swamp well
we're essentially living in the middle
of a swamp right now pretty much Orlando
used to be a swamp so but yeah so they
shot most but I think they actually I
think they shot at the fall in winter
time so maybe it wasn't quite as hot as
usual um but so she gets this hotel and
she's gonna fix it up because this is
kind of her last chance she's just been
sort of like drifting and aimless and
stuff and then um all of these like
really really creepy accidents like
start to happen and then she befriends
this blind girl named Emily who she
finds out later on is maybe not what she
seems so the thing about this like I
said I mean other than that very simple
plot synopsis it's just you know she
moves into this hotel and weird [ __ ]
starts to happen it's kind of just a
setup for all of the disgusting
[ __ ] that happens later on and like I
said it's just you know you get to see a
dude eaten by tarantulas there are three
count of three i gouging 'he's
in this movie one of them with a nail
you get to see a couple people nailed to
the wall like crucifixion style you get
to see a little girl get her head blown
off yeah in a very very famous yeah a
lot of weird ghosts and zombies and
pretty and pretty ghosts women and
zombie girls and little zombie girls you
know that's quite interesting actually
visually it's kind of it's impressive
yeah like I said it has like a
surrealistic sort of flair also it was
very much influenced by HP Lovecraft
and actually it's there's a little bit
of a deep cut
but the book that appears it's kind of
like an ongoing plot point in the movie
which is called the book of Ibon it just
says I'm on the front and it's just this
old book that is apparently talking
about you know the gates of hell and the
Dead will walk the earth and blah blah
blah the book of Ibon is actually a
Lovecraftian reference it turned up in a
few at least three of his stories one of
which was dreams in the which house so
he I thought that was kind of cool that
he's like well I'm not gonna use the
necronomicon necronomicon yeah you know
so I'm gonna go a couple deeper and like
mentioned some other [ __ ] that he
brought up and some of the other stories
so this does have like kind of a
Lovecraftian thing and if you look at it
in that context like you were saying
about Prince of Darkness
if you can kind of look at it as a sort
of we're opening up a Hell dimension and
all this crazy [ __ ] is gonna happen then
you can just kind of let it ride like
all this crazy [ __ ] happens and it's
fine kinda like into the mouth of
madness yeah yeah where it's like it's
it's not a lofty and spin off yeah and
it's the same kind of thing with like
this book and like you know there was
this guy named Schweich at the beginning
like a lot of love where he was
suspected to be a warlock and he could
be painting and then he got killed by a
mob and all this other stuff and then he
got like walled up and the basement and
somehow like discovering him like led to
this thing being opened mention in
Lovecraft and we were also talking about
you know like the thing in the carpenter
the thing maybe a Lovecraft story in the
book yeah in the mountains of madness
some guys go down to Antarctica and they
find an alien city
okay and while they're there a bunch of
stuff happens they they meet this thing
called ash a goth hmm which is common
amorphous slave creature that the old
ones had enslaved really the shag off is
the thing from the movie the thing yeah
okay so instead of fighting to see they
find an alien spaceship what I'm saying
is that the thing is kinda like a
take-off or carpenters version of the
thing kind of like a take-off on in the
mountains of madness yeah base
basically that same story and the thing
is a shag off the shag off is kind of
described as shape-shifting and having
eyes when it needed it in teeth when it
needed it and you know so that's that's
that same alien yeah and I kind of feel
like like I said carpenter particularly
you know he was influenced like I said
by Italian horror but he was also very
influenced by Lovecraft and a lot of his
movies had Lovecraft II and feel to them
yes all these guys are kind of using
Lovecraft as a as an inspiration for
their source material yeah and I feel
like um you know full she did the same
thing because the first the first movie
in the gates of hell trilogy which is
City the Living Dead it actually had a
priest hanging himself and that opened a
portal to Hell and the town was called
Dunwich so you know what I mean so he's
so he's using the same kind of thing and
like I said it was the same thing with
the book of Ibon which is kind of like a
demonic sort of thing and this and you
know it's kind of a thing where
initially in the initial treatment of
this I don't actually think that they
were supposed to be zombies or that was
supposed to be a zombie movie but
evidently some of the producers were
like well your movie zombie was so
popular that let's put some zombies in
there and it is New Orleans so it does
make sense they don't really feel
shoehorned in like I said cuz it does
really feel like you would have that
like if you know if a portal to Hell
open you would have like because I feel
like he was kind of inspired by the
whole you know when there's no more room
in Hell the Dead will walk the earth
like George Romero type of thing so I
feel like that was a factor as well
although I have to say my favorite
character in this is Emily the blind
girl she's super cool in this and super
cool looking like with those creepy
white contact lenses now you have to
think this was made this was shot in
late 1980 and they didn't have all these
little nice soft squishy contact me all
day he's got a ton of them these were
made of thick glass yeah and they were
hand-painted and you had to order them
special and when you wore them you could
legitimately not see anything so she was
playing a blind girl there like she
wouldn't playing a blind girl she was
blind she couldn't see
so it's like you know she's just walking
around with these [ __ ] things on her
eyes and you had to take him off like
every 15 minutes because your eyeballs
couldn't breathe so same kind of thing
there but you know like I said she's
kind of the coolest character because
she is ostensibly I mean you see her
normal like at the beginning and the
prologue and she's you know reading from
the book of eye bond or whatever but
then later on when you see her at first
the main character Eliza played by
Katrina McCall she thinks this is a real
person even though she sees her the
first time she sees her and I love this
shot Catriona is driving along the
causeway in Louise in New Orleans and
she sees the blind girl and her dog like
there's nobody around like this big
empty causeway and she's driving and
then all of a sudden she sees this girl
standing in the middle of the road and
there's just water on either side like
where did she come from and and all this
other kind of stuff so I love that shot
it's like so creepy but at first she
thinks this is a real person now there's
some kind of confusion about why emily
is i think she kind of escaped from hell
and then she kind of got in trouble with
the other you know corpses that had
escaped from hell because she tried to
warn liza about the hotel and about what
had happened there and she shouldn't
reopen it don't go in room 36 which was
kind of like a homage to The Shining I
think yeah you know that hold that hold
type of thing there the another thing
that that I thought of was that the
premise of this movie is actually kind
of similar to the premise to the
Sentinel from 1977 which actually we
have to do a show on because I love that
movie super creepy yeah and I haven't
seen it for a long time but it's like
it's really super creepy but it's not
it's it's a similar I mean it's not
really the same style or anything but
it's a similar kind of premise with like
I want to see again I want to see that
heat remember that one yeah we have to
do that one too yeah but that was I hope
we have such a huge list I want to buy
that one I think on blu-ray if I can
find it yeah it's like I know that I
love that as a kid I just haven't seen
it so long yeah I know that it takes
like a long time because I know that a
lot of you have requested movies and and
I promise that we will yeah you guys
were the requests get around to them but
yeah we have this humongous list I'm
like adding new ones all the time and
they have to prioritize them for
relevancy to other things that we've
talked about like it doesn't really make
sense to pull out a movie that isn't
related to anything else we haven't
talked about yet when when there's stuff
that we can say oh you know we we talked
about this let's bring this into the mix
so there's got to be common order in the
way things kind of unfold yeah and it'll
eventually will eventually get to it and
we're actually trying to get through
ones that we either own or that are
available on shutter or to B or
something like that so we're trying to
get like through all of those so we
don't have to like purchase new ones for
a little while because ya go to a movies
that it helps you unlock other movies
I'm talking about exactly exactly
we have to have some kind of a sane
ordered yeah and like I said I have been
wanting to do at least one Lucio Fulci
movie for a long time and when I saw
that that shutter had the Beyond and it
also has zombie and they have house by
the cemetery I don't think they have
city of the Living Dead but so I said
well let's do the beyond because that's
actually even though zombie is probably
a lot better known the beyond is
actually my favorite so I think it's his
best movie and like I said I want to do
the psychic as well but I don't own that
so we'll have to wait until I guess yeah
if we do the order right somebody could
go through our playlist it would almost
kind of play as as almost kind of like a
course yeah this really that's true yeah
I will be unfold yeah that's how I just
kind of thought of it instinctively to
kind of have a starting point with you
know like The Shining right it's
basically what we started with yeah
because that was our first episode yeah
it's a pretty milestone film and one of
my favorite horn not just my favorite
horror movies my favorite movies of all
time yeah it's one that I could watch
ever and ever night it's a cup but the
thing about okay so let's talk a little
bit about okay now the gore in this is
pretty much I mean eighty to ninety
percent very very well done it's
obviously our practical effects it was
made in the late nineteen or the late
1970s early 1980s there are a couple of
you know effects in there that didn't
really hold up so well especially the
the most infamous being the tarantula
scene where you know obviously some of
the tarantulas are real but obviously
some of them are decidedly not
doesn't really matter but it doesn't
really matter it's like he had like I
said it's 1980 and actually the effects
in this were actually quite a bit better
than some other movies that came out
around the same time period sometimes
when you see those old special effects
in the context of the time and the film
kind of that weird cheesy 80s practical
effects actually plays better in them I
think the reality I served a off it's
kind of like part of the character of
the flavor of the time yeah you know I
mean sometimes you see an effect and
it's not convincing but you just don't
care it's still cool yeah because you're
watching it you're watching the movie is
like a whole you know a whole Gestalt
like you know some of its parts
and you're also it's part of that
particular genre yeah you know like the
Evil Dead one would not be the Evil Dead
you remembered if that had awesome
special effects yeah it was like most of
its charm it would look like yeah and I
feel like that's what happens with a lot
of the Italian movies cuz like I said
now some of the effects in this like
when Martha gets her eyeball popped out
by the nail when Jill gets her head
blown off with the gun stuff like that
when when the one woman gets her face
melted off with acid those actually
still look pretty damn good
um also when Emily gets you know or
throat ripped out and things like that
it's like most of that looks pretty damn
good still well it's just like what is
it Star Wars a new hope their very first
Star Wars yeah well pretty practical
effects yeah
putting modern effects over those would
ruin that movie it would you know and
that's one thing that Lucas did he added
CG to it now some of the scenes actually
did kind of enhance it a bit with the
TIE fighters yeah but there's too many
damn creatures and moss eisely there's
too much [ __ ] Maas eyes he looked better
when it looked like a little rinky-dink
place out me it did he just doesn't know
when to stop he's just like that's why I
do you remember we saw on YouTube like
somebody made like a joke video about
Lucas like adding all this there's like
every single thing that happened there
would be a big monster like walking in
the front and they're like walking
behind it
it's like you couldn't he's just gonna
stop because up just add some more and
more that's more alien that's more
that's out some more flying [ __ ] that's
more it's like okay showing it down my
okis always kind of needed adult
supervision really that's a good way of
putting it
his you know the the the best movie was
the first one in the second one you know
I I think you know everybody agrees
Empire Strikes Back excuse me um yeah
Empire Strikes Back is is a is a classic
he didn't really do he didn't really
have a whole lot to do with that movie
that was directed and edited by the
people and new hope actually the
greatness of that movie came from the
Edit and he didn't do the Edit yeah they
should they actually some stuff has
escaped what that movie originally was
like before was all edited and as a
[ __ ] mess I mean it looked cheap
editors are the unsung heroes movie
industry yeah we salute you editors
because seriously you know yeah that you
can have the best you know vision in the
world
yeah but if you don't have somebody to
judiciously edit your [ __ ] together in a
way that it's like makes it coherent it
makes you you know plot move along and
stuff like that then your movies gonna
suck and now was one of the things with
Italian horror that kind of annoyed me
the Edit isn't real tight and yeah I
think the movies could have been a lot
better for at least I would have liked
him a lot better had they had a really
tight edits and they were really you
know plot driven or Cariah driven but
they don't really seem to be they seem
to be kind of meandering yeah like I
said they're more interested in like
surreal as though he's like showing
particularly yeah and I think it was
more like unsettling imagery I think the
story was built around certain scenes
that they wanted
that's exactly pretty much how they were
yes and generally have to have some
people eaten by trance with us we have
to have a couple of zombies we have to
have a ghost girl or how do we make this
work yeah and it seems like that's
essentially exactly what they did yeah
kind of backwards engineering but I feel
like I said that's a Kijana yeah as a
cultural thing and they were trying to
knock the movie out really that's it
you're just trying to do them so let's
just film these scenes and we'll worry
about it later
yeah we'll worry about it making sense
later yeah that's what they did although
you know what I mean and another thing
too I think another thing that sort of
is off-putting to people that are not
you
two Italian cinema of this era is that
pretty much all of them are dubbed
because for cheap you know I don't know
a lot about moviemaking but evidently
doing sound sync onset is sort of costly
and sort of complicated mostly back down
so yeah back then so what the Italians
would do is that they would usually and
also they usually had actors from lots
of different countries and some of them
speak the language for export Italy is
not a big enough market yeah I have to
have it available in every European
language right so what they would do
essentially is they would shoot the
movies silent and then they would have
they would have overdubs so everything
is over dubbed even if the people are
speaking English or if they're speaking
Italian dude they dub everybody and all
the sound effects are dubs and
everything like that so now some people
find that off-putting like I said it
doesn't bother me I think it used to
bother me more but once you get used to
it doesn't really bother me now although
house by the cemetery which is the third
movie in this trilogy very famously the
poor kid that played Bob in that movie
was dubbed so badly that even to this
day like full chief and still make fun
of it and I'm talking about like and
it's sad because the kid seemed like he
was doing a good job like an acting job
and stuff but the person that dubs his
voice it was just it was it was so bad
and it's like so now that's become kind
of like a funny like thing about the
movie even though I say I still really
like that movie and I think it's really
cool but another thing that I really
like about this movie too before we wrap
up now the ending of this is very
famously super bleak which I have really
really liked about it like pretty much
at the end of it the two protagonists
are like okay well we're [ __ ] forever
and then end originally and I just found
this out today the end of this movie it
was supposed to be they did go into the
other dimension and everything like that
but it was supposed to look like an
amusement park for whatever reason
because it was just like some kind of
weird dark amusement park or everything
so they were gonna do that initially but
then because they didn't have enough
money they were just kind of like no
let's do this instead we'll just film it
like in this big studio yep like a
blackstein it with sand all over the
floor they got a bunch of people to lay
down to be
corpses and they're just like this is
the hell dimension there's like nobody
here it's like you have to wander this
plane with all these corpses like for
the rest of your life and there's no way
to get out because you keep circling
around and you keep coming back to the
same place again which to me is actually
a lot more terrifying I think so I'm
actually kind of glad that they went
that direction instead of the amusement
park direction because I'm not sure not
so sure how well but yeah so I have to
show if you're watching on the video I
actually have this book here and it is
called beyond terror the films of Lucci
offal Chee and as you can see it is a
very very large book because he made a
really lot of movies not all of them
horror movies even though those are his
most famous if you don't know a lot
about Italian horror and you kind of
want to get into it then you could
there's probably worse places you could
start then the then the beyond because I
think like I said it's full cheese best
movie um as I said don't expect it to
really make a lot of sense you know just
kind of go with the surrealism go with
the dubbing just let it wash over you
like watching a painting it is kind of
because the imagery is very nice and
like I said Dario Argento's movies are
similar you know it's it's a different
style a little bit his they're a little
more operatic but it's kind of the same
thing if you're not expecting narrative
coherence you just want to look at it to
see like these amazing like gruesome
kind of tableaus and stuff then I think
you'll really dig them this is Tom has
actually only seen the Beyond and we
watch zombie also so he's not real up on
Italian horror this is kind of my thing
so I'm kind of glad we got it along but
I grew up with it I remember it yeah you
know I grew up with it there was a bunch
of myself that I even know the names of
them you know yeah yeah wait him on
cable back in those days all the time
you know yeah and you'd see him as the
dubbing and the way they were sharp they
didn't transfer out to television too
well like for instance I may have seen
this movie and just don't even remember
you might have yeah it looked good on
shutter yeah a good on a modern you know
HDTV yeah cuz the funny thing was when
they released this as seven doors of
death like I said on VHS and in the
theaters back in the 80s they really
really were trying hard and I they
probably did this with other Italian
movies too there
really trying hard like to not let
people know that it was Italian like you
know it's like people don't want to
watch them dirty foreigner movies so
they actually even in this one in the
beyond
they actually anglicize lucci offal
cheese names so it said directed by
Lewis fuller yeah well you know Italy
had a bad reputation yeah well they did
a lot of knock-offs
yeah they had a bad reputation for
quality at that time I remember with my
dad all his Italian he turn it because
they just had a bad reputation for just
shooting [ __ ] you know I mean yeah it
started with the westerns yeah they had
some good westerns but most of them were
terrible you know and they're forgotten
now yeah you know yeah only the good one
wasn't the test of time yeah but you
know a lot of movies that I grew up with
I had no idea how good they actually
looked until you see him in a modern
format exactly like you know I can go
back to escape from New York my favorite
movie I never got to see it in the
theater I saw it on TV and I liked the
idea but I didn't know that was a
beautiful movie until I got that
steelbook edition that steelbook edition
it on blu-ray you know it's that is a
pretty movie and you can see where
Carpenter used a lot of Italian lighting
techniques to shoot that yeah there's a
lot of guy who was the guy did super
Suspiria and Dario Dario Argento you
know like the blue and the green back
line and red although a lot of that
started with Mario Bava Mario Botta -
okay
so yeah because I remember you mentioned
it you know look how in this movie yeah
doesn't come across too well on on an
old television now we were seeing him
you know what I mean like back in the
cable days you didn't really see it that
well you see it on HDTV that's really
good that's why I'm really happy that
like a lot of these kind of cult classic
movies are now getting completely
restored and that you know being
released on blu-ray or even coming up on
shudder when the high-definition and
stuff like that and you really get a new
appreciation because like I said when I
rewatched the beyond I'm like wow I had
forgotten this is a gorgeous looking
movie it's like real all the shot
compositions are really nice and you
don't you just don't get that like from
the old like if you saw it on VHS or if
you saw it like just back in the old
days
it's like you know it looked all shitty
and it's like yeah stupid movie VHS and
cathode ray tube television boy just
didn't do these films just yeah we
didn't know any better well there was
nothing to compare it to really I mean
even when you went and saw stuff in the
theater it didn't look that great yeah I
mean depending on you know how it was
shot or what kind of film sake I wish it
looked really good on that new blu-ray I
got for dune that looks really good yeah
that looks like never seen dude look
that good
and we've I mean we've gotten a whole
bunch of movies like from that era
remember how good Flash Gordon looked
yes ash Gordon is beautiful that was my
glowing I had no idea that that is AD
ass movie who looked that good but on on
on blu-ray on a really good television
you can see the threads and the weave
inside the materials of the costumes you
can see how expensive those costumes
were yeah and it just that just did not
come across on television yeah
it's really giving me like yeah it's
really giving me like a new appreciation
for like a lot of those older movies cuz
how good that sound was yeah cuz like
look look how nice it looked and nobody
knew I guess until it was restored and
like I saw that in the theater and it
didn't look that good but I was cuz it's
just in a regular old crappy a steer a
bad back then it exactly eighties you
know in the 80s you're just like it even
the theaters couldn't do that movie
justice exactly it's like a because
nobody had high-definition nobody knew
what that was no it looked candy-colored
and just psychedelic and look like it's
straight out of a comic book yeah and it
was great they they actually made a
comic book movie but it just couldn't
come across with the technology at the
time yeah but now you've said it's time
say there's ahead of its time yeah but
that's the thing it's like in in some
ways ya miss the 80s and stuff like a
lot of good movies were made back then
but in a lot of ways like a lot of the
technology and [ __ ] was just [ __ ] it
wasn't like we have so much better stuff
yeah and I feel like it's you can
appreciate the movies a lot more because
they look so much better they look the
way they're supposed to look the way
they do
yeah and I would love for them to redo
Flash Gordon
like a deli style flashing around to it
I think with you know sexy perverted
aliens
fantastic costumes psychedelic clouds in
the background
no gravity or you know what those
gravity in space that's a good way to
put it yeah you know just like the old
just like the old flash Gordon's I think
that would I think now David's eg you
could do a great job with that
yeah Brian it has to be just off the
wall though yeah I I would be like goes
to the source material yeah I think they
should do it kind of like the original
just like run yeah like with those kind
of just over the top colors and
over-the-top costumes yeah and things it
just don't make sense and retro retro
technology yeah you know well like I
said is that's part of the charm bit
right and you know getting back to like
I said like Italian films it's like this
part of the charm in a movie is that
it's like we don't have it doesn't
really make a lot of sense and it's like
you know why is this woman in there
putting a suit on her dead husband in
the morgue and no one's stopping her and
then all of a sudden she falls and like
at quicklime or acid falls on her face
then she starts dissolving I'm just like
just don't question it you know [ __ ]
happens it just happens and just don't
worry about it
just enjoy the ride yeah so yeah so like
I said okay so I guess we will wrap up
this big win over meandering looking to
like I said our first Lucio Fulci movie
I'm hoping to do some more in the future
so if you if you like Italian horror you
know stay tuned we'll get to some more
later on and also this is gonna be our
last movie that our last movie review
before Halloween so everybody have a
good Halloween out there yeah it's good
Halloween
yeah and we're still working on the
Halloween special so that'll be out soon
too and remember if you like the show
like share subscribe on all your social
media if you'd like to financially
support the show you go to our patreon
page patreon.com/lenguin
our blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress.com and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account if you'd
like to give a one-time donation
remember our regular shows met every
Tuesday movie reviews come out every
Friday and our show matinee which is our
three new movies that we see every week
comes out on Sunday so check them all
out and until next time bye